us-russia tensions are rising this
morning after the Trump administration
officially backed out of a cold war arms
treaty withdrawal from a landmark
nuclear missile pact is raising fears of
a new arms race the u.s. accuses Russia
of violating the INF treaty by
developing banned weapons Russia denies
it the treaty prohibits
intermediate-range land-based missiles
it was signed in 1987 by President
Ronald Reagan and Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev the u.s. also may remove
thousands of US troops from Afghanistan
as part of a deal to end America's
longest war ever sources tell CBS News
the Trump administration is prepared to
reduce troop levels in Afghanistan from
about 14,000 to between 8 and 9 thousand
it would be part of a possible peace
agreement with the Taliban the u.s.
peace envoy to Afghanistan hinted
earlier this week a deal possibly could
be reached during upcoming talks in
Qatar two US soldiers were killed in
Afghanistan this week private first
class Brendan crusher of Stryker Ohio
and specialist Michael Nance of Chicago
are among 15 US troops who have died in
Afghanistan this year